Less than
37 hours of breathable air estimated
that's all the Coast Guard
estimates has left
for the five people on board
a submersible
that disappeared on a voyage
to visit the Titanic wreckage
at the bottom of the North Atlantic.
A massive search and rescue effort
continues some 900 miles
east of Cape Cod to find that vessel
which launched on Sunday.
On board is Stockton Ross.
He's the CEO of Ocean Gate.
That's the expedition company
that operates the submersible.
Also, our
with them are four other passengers.
CNN's Miguel
Marquez has the latest
from Newfoundland,
where the submersible started
its journey.
It's this is a complex search
a complex search now
more complicated by time,
which they're running out of.
We know there's about
there's about 40 hours of breathable air
left, deepwater submersibles and gear
converging on
Saint John's, Newfoundland, from the U.S.
and Canada.
It's the closest land to the search zone.
If the Titan can be found,
they'll need to bring all resources
to bear as quickly as possible.
You're dealing with a surface
search and a subsurface
search, and frankly,
that makes it
an incredibly complex operation.
The five person submersible
started its dove around 9 a.m.
Newfoundland time on Sunday,
its last contact with its mothership
The polar prince
was an hour and 45 minutes
into a dove, expected
to last just over 9 hours at 6:35 p.m..
Newfoundland time on Sunday.
The sub was reported
missing when it failed to surface
at the scheduled time of 6:10 p.m..
The vessel has oxygen for five people
for about four days.
But oxygen is only one critical element.
If they are alive
and they're in there,
they're going to be
at almost freezing temperatures.
Assuming they lost all their power.
That's why they can't communicate that
it's going to be dark, cold
and oxygen is there their
most precious resource
for so consuming that
staying calm, sleeping
the vessel and search area,
extremely isolated and deep.
Roughly 460 miles south
of Saint
John's, Newfoundland,
and 900 miles east of Boston
and possibly more than two miles
below the surface
where pressure is nearly
£6,000 per square inch.
Those on board
adventuring British billionaire Hamish
Harding, Pakistani businessman, father
and son Shahzad and Suleyman Dawood.
French explorer
Paul Henry Nardelli and CEO and founder
Stockton Rush, who owns Ocean
Gate Expeditions and the missing sub
so I want to give you a sense
of what's happening here
at Saint John's Harbor right now.
This is the Horizon Arctic.
It's the sister
ship to the Polar Prince
We believe this ship may be headed out.
There's a C-17 plane from the U.S.
that has just landed at the airport here.
It is going to bring gear down here.
A coast guard ship
from the Canadian Coast Guard
just left the harbor here
and is on its way to the search zone
as well.
Just a massive effort
and a lot of hope
that this one turns out well Jake.
All right.
Miguel Marquez in
Saint John's, Newfoundland,
thank you so much.
Let's bring in Mike Reese.
Mr.
Reese took the same voyage
on an ocean gate
vessel to
view the wreckage of the Titanic
11 months ago.
Mike, thanks for joining us.
We have a photo of you
on your own trip to see the wreckage.
Can you tell us what your experience
was like on the ocean gate voyage?
Yeah, it sounds a little grand
in every way
you felt like being a Mercury astronaut
like this.
This wasn't a vacation.
It wasn't tourism.
It was it was exploration.
And you're getting on a ship.
That's
the best it could be.
But they're learning as they go along.
And you
you get on with a lot of excitement,
but just constant trepidation,
constantly knowing this could be the end.
And in fact,
I was supposed to go with my wife
and she tested
positive for COVID
right before we got on.
And so I kissed her goodbye, knowing
that that might be
the last time I'd ever seen her.
So nobody walked into this,
you know, thinking
it was going to be a pleasure cruise.
And I, especially the the experts on bald
fact and Rose,
you know,
they made it as safe
as they could make it.
They trusted their own lives to
it, but they knew
it could end this way.
Mm hmm.
You did a podcast about your trip,
and you described
how the ship is controlled by a joystick
from a gaming console,
much like an Xbox controller.
Tell us about the technology
and how it works.
Yes.
As a lot of people have had focus on
that as it
this is some some jerry-rigged,
you know, crazy little jalopy
that's been slapped together
but it's one of the most reassuring
things about the submarine
is how very simple.
And once it's a pressure resistant to it
basically drops
to the bottom of the ocean.
It took
two and a half hours to go
kind of straight down.
And I actually fell asleep on the on
the trip down.
That's
how kind of relaxing
and meditative the whole thing is.
And once you reach the ground,
the ship is sort of piloted by two things
that just look like a fan
you would have on your desk. Very simple.
And it
is controlled by a joystick
from a gaming console.
So that even I was able to steer
and navigate the submarine for a while.
And again, these are all to the good.
I mean, simplicity
I think
would be
having something overly complicated
where you're
at the mercy of a lot of technology.
Nobody understands.
Yeah.
You also talked on your podcast
about how you had to sign a waiver
that warned
you at least twice that you could die.
I want to show this little clip.
CBS News
reported on this Ocean Gate submersible
and described another time when the ship
got lost Let's take a listen
There's no G.P.S.
underwater.
So the surface ship is supposed to guide
the sub
to the shipwreck by sending text messages
turn 30 degrees, right?
Probably 30 degrees.
But on this dove, communications
somehow broke down.
The sub never found the wreck.
We were lost.
We were lost for two and a half hours.
So this this appears to have happened
before
at least
getting getting lost
and losing communications.
I have to say, I took
four different dives with the company,
one of the Titanic and three of
of New York City
and communication with lost,
at least briefly every single time.
It just seems baked into the system.
I don't know.
I don't blame the submarine.
As much as I blame deep water.
But you would always lose it
and come back. And one thing is just the
the safety involved
these kind of things where
there was one dove we took
as soon as communication went up,
we went right back to the surface.
We were we'd go undersea
U-boat just off the shore of New York.
And we saw
we saw it for one second
and they said, we're going back up.
We we shouldn't be down here.
So, you know, they're not hot dogs.
They're not daredevils here.
They they take this very seriously.
Well, let's hope this story
has a happy ending.
Mike Reese, thank you so much.
Appreciate it.